>> AS I UNDERSTAND THEY ARE
DOING THAT FOR A FUTURE
PRESIDENTS THAT I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT PRECEDENT THE
ATTORNEYS SAY THAT THAT I DO IT
NOT FOR ME, THEY ARE DOING THAT
FOR THE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE FUTURE.
>> IF HE DOESN'T TESTIFY IT IS
TIME TO OPEN AN IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY.
>> Mike: THAT WAS PRESIDENT
TRUMP TO PENNSYLVANIA FOR A
RALLY TALKING ABOUT THE LATEST
BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN THE
WHITE HOUSE AND THE CONGRESS
OVER DON MCGANN, THE FORMER
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL WRITING A
LETTER TO CHAIRMAN JERROLD
NADLER OF THE HOUSE COMMITTEE
SAYING, THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE HAD ADVISED ME THAT HE
IS ABSOLUTELY IMMUNE FROM
COMPELLED CONGRESSIONAL
TESTIMONY WITH RESPECT TO
MATTERS OCCURRING UNDER HIS
SERVICE.
BECAUSE OF THIS CONSTITUTIONAL
IMMUNITY AND TO PROTECT THE
PREROGATIVES OF THE OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENCY, HE HAS DIRECTED
HIM NOT TO APPEAR AT THE
COMMITTEE SCHEDULED HEARING ON
TUESDAY MAY 21ST IN OTHER WORDS,
TOMORROW.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL.
BYRON YORK OF THE WARRANTOR
EXAMINER.
SUSAN PAGE, "USA TODAY" AND
KATIE PAVLICH, THEY NEWS EDITOR
AT TOWN HALL.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
LATEST?
>> THE STATEMENT WAS CLEARLY
MORE POLITICAL THAN THE DOJ MEMO
THAT THEY RELEASED ABOUT THE 15
PAGES THAT THEY DID FROM LISA
PROVED THAT THEY ARE READY FOR A
LONG TERM COURT BATTLE OVER THIS
SPECIFIC ISSUE WITH JERRY NADLER
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
WANTING TO CALL CORRECT STAFF
MEMBERS TO THE PRESIDENT TO
TESTIFY.
THE WHITE HOUSE EMPATHIZED AGAIN
TODAY THAT DON MCGANN TESTIFIED
FOR 30 HOURS AND POINTED OUT
THEY TURNED OVER 1.4 MILLION
DOCUMENTS AND THEIR FRIENDLINESS
AS, WE WILL NOT GIVE JERRY
NADLER AND REVIEW OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
BASED ON WHAT THE MEMO STATED
UNDER DIFFERENT ADMINISTRATIONS,
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS CITING
THE CLINTON ADMINISTRATION OF
THE NIXON ADMINISTRATION, THEY
ARE LOOKING AT THIS FROM A
BROADER PERSPECTIVE AND ARGUING
THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT THIS
ADMINISTRATION BUT THE PREVIOUS
SENIOR ADVISORS HAVE BEEN
PROTECTIVE BY THE PRESIDENT THIS
DOJ HAS SET IN NOT BEING FORCED
TO COMPLY WITH THE SUBPOENAS
BECAUSE IT'S A DIRECT ADVISOR TO
THE PRESIDENT >> Mike: WE
HEARD FROM THE LEADERSHIP TEAM
AND TO USE THE
WORD IMPEACHMENT.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> THEY TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
BUILDING A LINE OF ARGUMENT THAT
WAS USED BY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION AND THERE ARE
SOME MIXED HISTORY ON THIS UNDER
THE GEORGE W. BUSH
ADMINISTRATION.
THERE WAS A COURT DECISION THAT
SAID HE WOULD HAVE TO GO COMPLY
WITH THE SUBPOENA AND APPEAR
BEFORE A CONGRESSIONAL PANEL BUT
THEY ARE IN LINE.
THIS IS PART OF A BROAD EFFORT
BY THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION TO
DEFY CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATIONS ON EVERY FRONT
AND THAT IS ENORMOUSLY
FRUSTRATING AND IT DOES FEEL THE
DESIRE BY SOME HOUSE DEMOCRATS
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
IMPEACHMENT.
>> Mike: WHAT OF THOSE FRANCE
IS TRYING TO GET THE PRESIDENT'S
TAX RETURNS.
TAKE A LESSON.
>> WE DISAGREE WITH THAT RULING.
IT IS CRAZY BECAUSE YOU LOOK AT
IT, THIS NEVER HAPPENED TO ANY
OTHER PRESIDENT.
THEY ARE TRYING TO GET A REDO,
WHAT WE USED TO CALL IN SCHOOL A
DO OVER AND IF YOU LOOK, WE HAD
NO COLLUSION, WE HAD NO
OBSTRUCTION, NO NOTHING.
>> Mike: BEING FROM NEW JERSEY
I AM USED TO THE TERM AND DO
OVER.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON TRYING
TO GET DON MCGANN TO THE HEALTH
OF THE FINANCIAL RECORDS?
>> THE FINANCIAL RECORDS FROM
HIS ACCOUNTING FIRM AND I THINK
HE WAS GOING TO LOSE THAT.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE A STRONG
ARGUMENT, CONGRESS DOESN'T HAVE
A PURPOSE IN GETTING THIS
INFORMATION AND THE JUDGE I
THINK IT IS NOT GOING TO TELL
CONGRESS WHAT ITS PURPOSE IS.
ON THE DOG BEGAN THINK I THINK
IT IS DIFFERENT.
I THINK THE WHITE HOUSE IS ON
SOLID GROUND HERE.
THEY DID CITE EVENTS FROM THE
GEORGE W. BUSH OF ADMINISTRATION
AND FROM OBAMA THESE ARE CASES I
THINK IT WHICH THEY REALLY DON'T
WANT TO GO TO COURT.
I DON'T THINK THEY WANT A
DECISION, BOTH SIDES WITH
CONGRESS OF THE WHITE HOUSE.
ESPECIALLY IN THE BUSH CASE, THE
CONGRESS SUBPOENAED HARRIET
MIERS WAS A WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL
AND KARL ROVE IN 2007.
THEY DID THAT FOR TWO YEARS,
FINALLY THEY AGREED TO GO TALK,
BUT WITH EXTREME LIMITATIONS.
ONLY ON THE SUBJECT THAT WAS AT
HAND WHICH WAS THE FIRING OF A
LOT OF U.S. ATTORNEYS AND THEY
WOULD NOT TALK ABOUT ANY
CONVERSATION THEY HAD HAD WITH
THE PRESIDENT.
DON MCGANN GOES UNDER THOSE
CONDITIONS THE DEMOCRATS WILL BE
VERY UNHAPPY.
>> Mike: YOU HAVE THE
PRESIDENT GOING TO PENNSYLVANIA
TONIGHT AND 20 PLUS DEMOCRATS
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
>> PEOPLE DON'T REALLY CARE
ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
PEOPLE IN NEW HAMPSHIRE AND IOWA
AND MICHIGAN AND WISCONSIN,
DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO TAKE
BACK VOTERS, RUSSIA AND
PRESIDENT TRUMPS TAX RETURNS
WHICH HE DIDN'T RELEASE ARE NOT
AT THE TOP OF THEIR LIST.
BACK IN WASHINGTON THAT HAS
HELPFUL TO DEMOCRATS OR RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT FOR DEMOCRATS ON
THE HILL TO BE SUBPOENAING
INFORMATION TO TRY TO EMBARRASS
THE PRESIDENT TO MAKE HIM LOOK
LIKE HE HAS NOT COMPLYING WITH
THE SUBPOENAS LIKE HE IS HIDING
SOMETHING.
THAT WILL BE POLITICALLY HELPFUL
TO THEM WHEN IT COMES TO A
GENERAL ELECTION FOR THEM TO DO
THE RESEARCH.
>> Mike: WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS?
>> I AGREE WITH YOU THAT THIS
ISN'T ON THE TOP OF VOTERS
MINDS.
THEY SAY HEALTH CARE AND
REGISTRATION, BUT AMONG THE
STRONGEST ACTIVIST I DO CARE
ABOUT HOLDING THE PRESIDENT
ACCOUNTABLE AND ABOUT BEING ABLE
TO INVESTIGATE AND DOING THE
OVERSIGHT THAT REPUBLICANS
DECLINED TO DO DURING THE FIRST
TWO YEARS OF HIS 10-YEAR PERIOD
THAT CREATES I THINK SOME RISK
FOR DEMOCRATIC LEADERS BECAUSE
HOW DO THEY MANAGE THAT DESIRE
TO INVESTIGATE THE PRESIDENT
AGAINST THE KNOWLEDGE THAT THE
ISSUES ARE SOMETHING ELSE?
>> Mike: SOME FRESH REACTION
FROM DON MCGANN'S ATTORNEY
SAYING THAT HE WILL RESPECT THE
PRESIDENTS INSTRUCTION ABOUT NOT
TESTIFYING TOMORROW.
WHAT ABOUT THE POLITICS?
>> THIS WILL GO ON.
I THINK THIS LACK OF INTEREST
AMONG THE MOTORS AND WE HAVE
GODLY MUELLER REPORT, THERE IS A
LOT OF INFORMATION AND IT HASN'T
SEEMED TO CHANGE A LOT OF MINDS.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE PRETTY OPEN
ABOUT THIS, THEY REALIZE THAT
MOST PEOPLE DIDN'T DIG INTO THE
MUELLER REPORT, THERE IS SOME
ARCANE LEGAL ARGUMENT AND THEY
WOULD LIKE TO CREATE A SIMPLE TV
SHOW OUT OF BED AND HAVE A
DRAMATIC WITNESS, TESTIFIED IN
FRONT OF CONGRESS AND MAY BE
THEY CAN GET SOME INTERESTING
PERSONAL INFORMATION AND IT
COULD BE A SHOW THAT PEOPLE
ACTUALLY ATTACH THEMSELVES TO.
THAT IS WHY THEY WANT HIM TO
TESTIFY SO BADLY AND THEY WOULD
CERTAINLY LIKE TO GET ROBERT
MUELLER AS WELL.
THAT IS ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
THE WHITE HOUSE AS RESISTING.
HE COOPERATED ENTIRELY WITH THE
CRIMINAL PROCEEDING, 30 HOURS OF
TESTIMONY, TONS OF PAGES OF
MATERIAL.
THE WHITE HOUSE DOES NOT WANT TO
LET THEM CREATE THIS TV SHOW.
>> Mike: THEN THERE IS THE
MICHIGAN CONGRESSMAN, HE HAS A
TENDENCY TO HEADS WITH HIS
LEADERSHIP CALLING FOR
IMPEACHMENT NOW, A TWITTER
BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN
HIMSELF AND PRESIDENT TRUMP OVER
IMPEACHMENT.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS?
>> REPUBLICANS ARE KNOWN FOR
BEING IN LOCKSTEP WHICH IS A
GOOD THING.
WHEN IT COMES TO JUSTIN AMASH
BUT HAS PASSED POSITION ON CIVIL
LIBERTIES, I FIND IT QUITE
INTERESTING THAT HE TOOK THE
POSITION OF IMPEACHMENT WENT
THERE SO MUCH EVIDENCE OF THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE SITUATION OF
THE FBI AND PROPERLY USING THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND THE DNC
AND THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN TO GO
AFTER A POLITICAL OPPONENT WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE POTENTIAL OF
THE FISA ABUSE SO AFTER READING
THE REPORT I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE SAYING, WE HAVE COME
TO A VERY DIFFERENT COLLUSION
BUT HE IS ENTITLED TO HIS
OPINION AND CERTAINLY
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS THAT OPINION
ABOUT IT AS WELL.
>> Mike: NANCY PELOSI TOLD US
THAT THEY NEED SOME
BIPARTISANSHIP IN THE SENATE TO
GO ANYWHERE WITH IMPEACHMENT.
>> HER STANDARD HAS BEEN A
PATIENT GO FORWARD IF THERE IS
NOT BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
JUSTIN AMASH DOES NOT SURPRISE
THAT.
HE SPEAKS ONLY FOR HIMSELF.
THERE IS ONE WAY HE COULD CREATE
BIG PROBLEMS AND THAT IS IF HE
RUNS AS A LIBERTARIAN NOMINEE
FOR A PRESIDENT AND HE SAYS THAT
IS A POSSIBILITY.
WE KNOW THAT HE COMES FROM A KEY
STATE THAT THIRD PARTY
CANDIDATES DO NOT HAVE TO GET A
LOT OF VOTES TO AFFECT THE
OUTCOME AND THAT MATTER IN
MICHIGAN.
>> THIS COULD BE A CRACK IN THE
DAMP, SOMETHING THAT WOULD BUILT
INTO SOMETHING MUCH BIGGER AND
THAT
DOES NOT APPEAR TO BE HAPPENING
AT ALL AND OF COURSE THE BIGGER
ISSUES AS A SENATE AND BIT
ROMNEY FOR GOODNESS' SAKES SAID
HE DID NOT AGREE